before we continue I'd like to give a
shout out to the sponsor of this video
Shadow verse Shadow verse is a
multiplayer turn-based anime card game
with a fun-loving community of over 1
million daily players now personally I
really like the amazing anime styled
character artwork who have fully voiced
in English and Japanese it's free to
play on PC and mobile and guess what you
can get 50 free card packs for just
finishing the tutorial it's a highly
strategic game and you can play your way
thanks to 8 distinct leader classes and
a multitude of cards designed by some of
the world's best card game players
click the link in the description if
you'd like to check out the game they
say that rivalries are the foundation of
success for anime this is true
especially in a world full of thrilling
battles and long drawn-out storylines
not only that rivalries allow for
further development of character or a
way to cap off something that's been
brewing for so long in a majestic finale
it goes without saying that most
rivalries end in a blow off fight some
of the fights are more notable while
some are quite mediocre in this video
we're gonna count down what's our in my
opinion 10 of the best anime rivalry
fights in the medium we may have some
top rivalries in anime but what are
rivalries without those blower fights
anyway
boom go stray dogs had a lot of cool
fights to its credit but I think the one
that stands out the most to me is the
battle between our sushi and Akutagawa
the battle specifically the rematch pits
the overpowering shadows of Rashomon
against art sushis transformations once
again a sushi tries a different approach
this time round the new techniques
worked quite well at first before
Akutagawa brushes everything off with
Rashomon however one thing Rashomon
fails to do is to put down its wielders
determined opponent for good even space
itself wasn't enough to prevent art
sushis come back who does it in an epic
manner for watches to remember for years
to come seriously wrong go stray dogs is
just so underrated for the great action
it has the next fight is probably
unexpected but nonetheless a great one
from a childhood classic for a lot of us
it's Yugi versus Kaiba from Yugi O's
Battle City arc this has been one of the
showcase rivalries in the entire series
of yu-gi-oh so much that decades after
the first season ended konami is still
producing movies of the original series
one which starred kaiba and focused on
his rivalry with yugi for a card game
anime i think their culminating fight in
the battle city ark is one of the best
rivalry climaxes you can ask for
spanning over a month of actual runtime
in japan the fight featured a sequence
of events that displayed how a climax
fight in a card game anime show should
be you see all the key cards being
played in a swingy affair and the fight
also featured a nifty cut to a preview
for the ancient lore about ancient Egypt
that looms over the series setting up
the next arc not only did the fight
feature the best out of both of the
characters it also had an emotional
impact and nicely set up the next arc
and the deeper law of the series is no
doubt one of if not the best jewels in
the series
[Music]
if there's a fight that encapsulates the
raw intensity in bleaches Arrancar argh
it's definitely his second go against
Grimmjow for me Grimmjow is the best
rival for Ichigo as someone who can
match his beats with sheer force instead
of someone who has a contrasting
personality as we can see with most
Ichigo rivals in addition to the action
and the drives that the character showed
in this battle the reveal of grim Joe's
new form and abilities also made this
fight a very memorable one for Bleach
fans the fight also ended in a simple
yet impactful manner with Ichigo simply
overcoming the sheer intimidation and
pressure brought about by grim jazz new
techniques and finishing it with a
resolute strike this is a fight that
shows of how far our hero has come and
how well he matches up with probably his
fiercest foil and Bravo and like most
other rivalry fights that feature
Ichigo getting beaten around before
finding a way to come back this one
seems the most balanced and intense one
especially compared to his final fight
against ulquiorra in that very same arc
correct me if I'm wrong I'm pretty
positive that among the numerous fights
in Hajime no Ippo only a select few can
even come close to the hype of it bow
and send o's rematch in terms of actual
fights it's right up there being on par
with blockbusters like taka Mura vs.
hawk the ippo vs. sendou fight firmly
cement sendou as one of the most
formidable fighters in this series even
giving it Bo the whole underdog energy
that encouraged fans all over the world
to cheer a true championship bout if
you've ever seen one for this specific
fight I think they're seeing it bow and
send o Duke it out in anime format made
it even better but there's a moment in
anime history where the animation
soundtrack and voice acting made an
already awesome fight an even bigger
deal it's this
[Music]
other cards decisive battle against
Anderson isn't just one of the top
rivalry fights out there it's also one
of the best anime fights in the new
millennium in terms of pure spectacle
it features possibly the most broken
vampire in existence in the anime world
taking on the one being that seemingly
stood a chance against him well for a
while at least anyway I think that a
number of us Helsing watchers already
knew that Andersen wouldn't be leaving
the fight alive and even he arguably had
the same sentiments Alucard is also too
proud to not allow himself to die just
like that and when Andersen transformed
it awakened the former's pride and
pushed him to kick the training wheels
off nonetheless Anderson was gonna give
a Liu card hell before biting you and in
this fight that's become one of
Helsing's defining moments he sure did
in a pre lead to the long and wild ride
that is the shishio arc we have Kenshin
taking on site though in a battle
between two swordsman who are more than
familiar with each other thanks to their
shared history while not as
overwhelmingly powerful as shishio Saito
provides Kenshin the much-needed warm-up
fight before starting the next part of
the saga in fact I'd say that site
though being not as powerful as shishio
is one of the reasons I like this fight
much more he serves as a better opponent
for Kenshin
thanks to their complementing
philosophies and skill level and the
result fight is a treat to watch both
emotionally and visually not only that
the fight also featured some nice nods
to Kenshin's manslayer personality for
something that could have been just a
way to kick-start an arc with a bang
this fight really deserves some
recognition
[Music]
Goku versus Vegeta has pretty much
become synonymous to the concept of
anime rivalries a long documented
rivalry with many battles to show for it
I think the most important for me
narrative Lee speaking is the one
featuring margin Vegeta for someone as
proud and competitive as Vegeta I saw
his act of sacrificing his ties for more
power coming a mile away who better to
be his opponent in the showcase fight in
that form than his eternal rival Goku
the fight itself was great but I think
that the best part of the fight was
seeing character depth from it while
Vegeta sacrificed bonds for power we can
also argue that Goku held back in the
confrontation making an even starker
contrast between the two rival fighters
overall the fight is great and
admittedly it's version in the anime has
so much padding but did you expect
anything else out of Dragon Ball
Bakugan versus midoriya is interesting
for me Midori a story of slowly becoming
a true hero from being the underdog
without a quirk has been one of the
narratives that have captured the heart
of anime fans in the past decade
standing on the opposite side of our
plucky hero is his hot-blooded and proud
childhood friend the combustible Baku go
the tension that they had with each
other would erupt in a battle thanks in
large part to the resentment from Baku
ghosts sense of entitlement the battle
itself was great
featuring back and forth action with
midoriya even whipping out some cool new
tricks and powers in the heat of the
battle I think the biggest surprise here
though is having Baku go actually come
out on top in the actual battle however
with all might still sticking by his
decision after the battle and giving the
victor a lecture it seems to be one of
those won the battle but lost the war
moments
I think everyone saw this coming a mile
away why have a top-10 rivalry fights in
anime video without featuring one of the
era defining rivalries in the world of
shown in anime among the numerous
encounters in the series the final
battle between Naruto and Sasuke was one
that struck me the most in my opinion
the fight is great as a fight with all
those powers on display I would rather
forget the spectacle that the anime
version of the fight gave us in favor of
the underlying message and how well it
wraps up the key themes of the series
and Naruto's own journey from the start
having the battle end in a technical
draw but an ideological win for Naruto
is brilliant it's a fight not about
Naruto just overpowering the opponent
but about finally reaching the cold and
yielding heart that eluded him for much
of the series run while paving the way
for the epic conclusion of the whole
story naruto vs sasuke just falls short
of the number 1 spot because for me
there's just one more fight that drew
out more emotion and chills out of me
[Music]
not all rivalry fights have to have
flashy fireworks extravagant effects and
complicated techniques perhaps more
arguably the best rivalry fight in anime
just needs is a good dose of emotion
great cinematography and a long
well-written story for it to culminate
its with those categories that I place
kintoki versus dark asougi as the number
one rivalry fight in anime in episode
304 of the animate the two longtime
rivals go at it with an exchange that's
quite graphic and filled with emotional
blows the fight seems less explosive
than what you'd expect from the kings
have shown in anime but even would just
sort techniques and heavy-handed blows
you could really feel the atmosphere
with each blow that the fighters land
and the amount of emotional investment
the fight has for Gintama z' loyal
followers a lot of people argue that
this is the peak of Gintama and after
watching this by multiple times I'm
inclined to agree
[Applause]
with that we wrap up this edition of the
list rivalries have really spice up
anime and those are the 10 with the best
climactic fights in my opinion do you
think any other rivalry fights deserve a
spot on this list I'd love to hear your
thoughts if that's the case please like
and subscribe for more content if you
enjoyed this video and I'll be seeing
you next time don't forget to check out
our sponsors game Shadow verse the links
in the description it's a free to play
game and clicking on the link will
really help out the channel keep
yourself safe have fun and I'll see you
next time on beanie tube
[Music]